- [Kelly] I wanna ask, you know, because
we're now finally having
a real conversation
about white privilege.
I actually watched a lot of things you do,
and 'cause I'm a fan
of yours, but last year
you did a documentary called
"Hello Privilege, It's Me, Chelsea"
and you were way ahead
of the curve on that one.
But what inspired you to do that,
and what did you learn from it?
- [Chelsea] Well, I wrote, well,
I wrote my last book "Life
Will Be The Death Of Me"
which was about going to therapy
for the first time in my life.
And when I did go to therapy
for the first time in my life,
after Trump was elected in 2016,
I had a lot of anger,
and I had a lot of rage
about him being elected,
and I didn't understand.
And so I had to do some
really deep digging
to A: what was going on with me
and my reaction to that,
and why I couldn't calmly discuss it,
you know, instead of like with my veins
popping out of my neck,
and tweeting while I'm sleeping,
trying to actually get
ahold of my emotions
and be in a place where I'm
responding not reacting,
you know, and through that work
and like going to therapy
seriously for a while,
I just, it was just, obvious to me
how I had failed to look around
and see how the color of my skin
has been such a benefit to my own success.
So I was very interested
in doing a documentary
about finding out what
does white privilege mean?
Because to me it just meant
people who go to Harvard
or go to those, you
know, Ivy League schools
or the Rockefellers.
I thought that was white privilege
when I started that documentary.
And then you learn that,
no, you don't have to
go to an Ivy League school,
your family doesn't have to be wealthy,
for it to be a privilege
to have white skin.
You are benefiting from a system
that other people - that is hurting
other people.
As long as people are hurting,
then there is a group of people that are
benefiting from that.
That's just the way it works.
And so it opened my eyes so much,
and I just loved that film,
and I had to say...
It was a film to white people,
to say "Listen, I know these conversations
are uncomfortable, but
we should be having them
because we have a problem
in this country."
- [Kelly] And without
you being uncomfortable
I don't think change will even occur.